this is entitled and this is why your
band should not go them for warrant it
was nineteen eighty-four when I moved to
Los Angeles from small redneck town of
7,000 people in Northwest I came to Los
Angeles ostensibly to be an artist I
knew I had to get away fast and far from
the monster truck rallies and cater a
party existence of my teenage years as
quickly as I could that meant flying to
either Los Angeles or New York New York
I'd seen Tax Guide there's no
way that was happening besides Los
Angeles was the home to the bands that I
loved I might as well have been a
prototype for Axl Rose and welcome to
the jungle video kasey kid with big hair
and bigger dreams and absolutely no
clue comes to hollywood at the
apex of the metal explosion Motley Crue
doc and rat poison wasp quiet right
dozens and dozens and dozens of others
emerged from the city and by god I was
going to make it mine I was surely just
like the thousands and thousands of came
every single month during that year now
Los Angeles in Hollywood in the 80s was
a very different place I wasn't close to
being the same as it is now you could
taste the air in mornings when we walked
out because of the pollution hairspray
was truly toxic in plasticine it was
genuinely a dangerous town at times
deadly but most of all the someone in
their late teens early 20s with that
undeniable sense of invincibility and
immortality it was exciting as in
this cleaned up safe sex post just say
no 12 step in present day we live in
it's almost impossible to convey to
someone who wasn't there just the depths
how deep the depths of decadence could
die communities at one another time in
what other place could you possibly own
classmates shut your dorm rooms and
evolve pure coke that they liberated
from their companies your father's coat
they have we share it with you no
strings attached there's always strings
attached but that's a story for another
day one of my first jobs in Los Angeles
was as a storyboard production artist
for rock videos videos with the bands
that inspired me bands I'd spent scores
of stoned hours in the dark of my room
listening to our pgo guitars and
screaming caterwauls letting the sonic
power tear away things like hesitation
second-guessing in fear those of us who
love metal during this time yeah we
heard the arguments
that there was backmasking in the songs
that would mean gullible and weakest
there's do horrible things that they
kill people they kill themselves like
the albums were sponsored by the NRA or
something we knew that was but
there was magic and if you listen
closely it would whisper to you between
the staccato double beat of a bass drum
you can be anything they will walk in
July and tell you you can't do not
listen you have a greater destiny than
they can possibly comprehend and I've
accepted that magic anybody hard I let
that spell be cast and look here I was
nine months later 18 years old like
standing in for Steven Tyler as they set
lights i'm watching Tawny Kitaen ride on
the hood Marty collars Jack I'm watching
Paul Stanley do that weird host step
dance he didn't elevate and yes and no i
never did ask what the i was about
these gigs led to need medium deterring
keyboard player for deal we talked in
there that was a singer he told me there
was a group of guys i needed to talk to
because they had a band they were from
her Washington is one and they need a
singer and supposedly they rocked I went
to their practice room in Hollywood I'd
listen to him they did indeed rock their
guitars stopped that Megadeth Metallica
were quote-unquote anyway quote
unquote show them what it really meant
to shred that Dave wasn't giving hollow
books I've never seen a to guitar team
played
babs that precise a perfect harmony it
was like Bach our methedrine it was
amazing and we hit it off the phones
daddy would deep and meaningful lyrics
socially he'll we're very serious on
subject matter to match the multiple
time changes and insanely complex melody
lines songs got better we got tighter
and he truly felt like we had something
special going on musician friends of
ours who are in mid-level man's I got
the trans and rough cut they agreed this
was something different top of the
word mom and one day the
other guitarist mike comes in meaning
like we just he just had a day of free
lap dances at the Tropicana and he said
boys were playing the troubadour for kid
they grew up reading about the lands of
love that they played three venues
gazzarri's the whiskey or the troop now
a significant difference between those
bands and us they are we read and the
era they had and that was that every
club in order to make money off of the
20 wannabe rock bar rock stars that were
in every square block of Los Angeles was
there was a policy now he'll pay for
play each man has given a block of
tickets when you had a venue it is your
responsibility is that we had to sell
them he could sell them for five dollars
ten dollars sometimes fifteen dollars
but you are responsible for selling your
entire block before the show that also
meant that you had to pay the club if
you didn't sell every ticket so not only
were you not making any money for a
venue dick but there were odds that were
very hot you lose money in a lot of it
Gabe's reaction do this socks
yeah well you know at least four play
the tree everyone says reviewed
something special we just have to look
at it as cost of doing business will
it's signed yeah look inside then Dave
noticed on the ticket above our names
special guests our imagination went nuts
coming up with a million combinations
who could it be Catherine's crews
working on the new album maybe them
queens right had been spotted in town
working on a new video who could it be
I'll spare you the living hell of 15
days walking up and down Sunset
Boulevard trying to hand sell tickets to
every single person they walked by when
the people directly behind us and people
directly in front of us are doing the
exact same thing we got rid of all the
tickets find the night came we're
playing the truth small town redneck me
is freaking the out so when the
other guys but we dealt with it in the
calm and rational professional manner
dave was a raging alcoholic Mike was a
stoner me I learned them to our
Northwest heritage to the philosophy
what's my drug of choice well what do
you got we've got a 25 minutes set as
we're loading in the promoter comes by
and gives us the rundown if we go along
they cut our ramps Dave Don's Mike knows
I know there's a lot of naughty look
cool or cold all our songs are round
eight minutes long so we'll do 3 mount
Mike then ask question the question so
this is special guest the promoter gran
is the biggest happiest most genuine
green I've ever seen on these scum
sucking that run promotions what
and put this in perspective this is
priya cherry pie pre Bobby Brown March
but it wasn't pre holy you've gotta
be kidding these guys make
poison see my Motorhead warrant
my client try and call Dave down Dave ha
squawk was set at least 400 times
during the 60-second period setting a
new world record we pointed out that
label people would be there we busted
are asked to sell all of those stupid
tickets for this reason and mutual
loathing of the headlining band could
not stand in her way David Green Mile
perfect member vanity and headed over to
the bar he appeared right as we were
going on again his item has slung over
his shoulder a fifth of vodka in each
hand Mike and I look each other in the
shrug David was a professional job he
was like a Bukowski with finger tabby
we'd seen him play under alcoholic
conditions that would put less Herman
into the hospital we were not worried
the first 5th was down by the time we've
done the first song eight minutes
one-fifth what could possibly go wrong I
didn't have time to worry about Dave I'm
trying to get over on the audience
trying to connect them I'm feeling like
Daltrey and Tommy going see me hear me
and they're giving me stone walls blank
expressions are the best reaction many
of them look too many of them look in
horror like I've raped the corpse of
their beloved family pet in front of
them finally 23 minutes 45 seconds later
we finish Dave with the half of the
remaining fifth of vodka in his hand
grabs the mic from me and screams into
it you and stumbles away there's a
reason we didn't let Dave right lyrics
and with that we're going to go stage
immediately blocked by the promoter and
the single warrant Jane Lane he shoves
us yelling where the stars here here's
you worry mama us man that widdly widdly
widdly what the is that Dave
stands overlooks nonplussed spins the
fifth in his hand like some acrobatic
drunken ninja and brings it down with
full force over Jamie's head saying
you it shatters there's vodka there's
glass there's blood all flying in slow
motion there are hands on us they're
shoving us Janie's head is on the ground
bleeding his eyes are closed is he dead
well this will be a real hoot if it is
their screams dave is calculated as the
owner yells Thomas we're done in this
town we will never play at any venom
ever again we dealt with this in a calm
and rational the professional meter Mike
was a stoner to me I got my card next
morning and drove back to Washington and
this is why your bed should have it
under Laurent